c'est une semaine dont toutes les
joueuses rêve qui s'achève pour illana
rupert meilleur jeune jouer en euroligue
et en ligue féminine
retenu dans le groupe france pour l'euro
et surtout draft en w une fois que
commandant a été appelé j'ai vraiment pu
souffler j'étais vraiment très ému parce
que ça a toujours été un rêve d'être
assez et voilà le fait que ça arrive
enfin
j'étais vraiment très très contente et
très ému tout ça à 19 ans seulement et
après une saison compliquée attendu
qu'ovide en début d'année et blessé a
lâché j'ai travaillé dur j'étais quand
j'étais à l'insep ma blessure pour
revenir sur les terrains et c'est une
belle concrétisation de tout travail qui
a été fait avec son mètre 93
elle domine sur les parcs et agile en
attaque
solides en défense et souvent présentes
au robot yen à rupert trace son chemin
et impose son jeu que ce soit sur le tir
extérieur ou des tirs de prayssas sa
capacité à finir à finir de plusieurs
manières ça c'est quelque chose qui est
qui est très bien mais le truc le plus
le plus incroyable chez elle vu son âge
c'est sa compréhension du jeu et comment
elle est capable voilà de s'ajuster ça
c'est ça c'est très forte chez les rues
père le basket est une histoire de
famille il y en a foulé parquet dès
l'âge de 4 ans en suivant les traces de
son père pour chalon sur saône ou encore
le mans des clubs qui la feront grandir
avant d'intégrer l'insep puis bourges
avec rapidement le statut de grand
espoir du basket
c'est vrai que j'ai souvent surtout
quand j'étais plus jeune j'étais fille 2
mais je pense qu'à partir du moment où
on a gagné l'euro en 16 à bourges et que
j'ai été mvp de la compétition
j'ai vraiment vu la différence et je me
suis on va dire détachées et on se
rappelait vraiment de
nous prennons avant de s'envoler pour
las vegas viana aura de grands défis à
relever
d'abord conclure la saison avec bourges
puis l'euro avec l'équipe de france et
ses premiers jeux olympiques au japon
l'année des premières fois celle dont
elle se souviendra longtemps dans sa
carrière de basketteuse